hey everybody and welcome to a checkered
wild ride with steo we've got Johnny
Knoxville the captain and let me tell
you he is shockingly candid about his
checkered pass completely caught me off
guard the way that he just opened up
about the way that we used to behave in
the past with all the pills and the
booze and the women and man is this one
juicy we talk about old stuff new stuff
and the exciting new project that he and
I are working on right now this is Juicy
this is fun and before we get into it I
want to thank everybody for making my
bucket list special way more successful
than its predecessor gnarly thank you
for going to sto.com and checking that
out and now let's get to it people of
the Universe I bring to you Johnny
Knoxville well I'm glad to oh there goes
the mic I'm glad to be here steo thank
you for having me again and with Wendy
yeah it's um it's uh just kind of a a
tough thing for me to live with that
your previous episode on our wild red
podcast is by far in a way the most
viewed most listened to episode that we
ever did and all was was an exercise and
you sitting down for me to talk at you
the whole time and tell you your
stories Emily's like what happens on his
podcast I'm like you just listen to him
talk it's
fine yeah I asked you about big brother
and he told your whole story about big
brother and uh you know and and with
that said I think that it was a
reasonably entertaining episode but but
since then it's been important to me to
grow to uh improve my my conversational
etiquette now do you think you have
improved I believe I really genuinely
have okay do you not I
do I mean I think so I've been here what
three minutes and I've said three words
so I think he's done much
better I feel my face turning red um but
uh but yeah no I I want to uh to to
really get into it and uh and and make
it a a better episode so we've got even
like kind of a game plan of questions we
got some hardit questions for you okay
okay um first off how you doing I am
effing wonderful steo good doing good
doing good um you didn't have your uh
your dog last time your dog's a newer oh
bucket yeah that's why Wendy she could
smell bucket on me bucket is uh yeah
she's the complete center of our life
it's great yeah she sleeps with Arlo
every night and uh just
misbehaves and uh yeah we're very happy
we got her from a rescue mut Scouts they
found her in a trash can in Tijana wow
and uh Emily sent me a photo of her and
said I love that trash dog so I kind of
got her for Christmas for Emily and the
kids wow yeah and um you just came from
uh shooting a TV show is that yeah
password with Jimmy f
I did a couple of episodes first one I
didn't do so good folks but uh cuz I I
got I I you know usually on TV or
whatever I'm not nervous at all
but and I've done game shows but we're
playing for ourselves or charity and but
I'm playing for the contestant and I
want them to win so I was like yeah so
um but I think eventually got there but
uh it's a fun
game was that jackass Family Feud for
charity it would have had to have been
yeah yeah yeah that was all for charity
Tain lost for charity
yeah tour I was on tour so I couldn't
make it and um man I I I regretted that
I couldn't make that because uh it it
was really like I saw it everywhere yeah
it supposed to be a 30-minute episode
but they kept us forever and then they
made it their season finale made it an
hour episode so yeah it was uh God we
almost lost we were like lost every
round until the very last thing and I
would have been so embarrassed what was
it like to have danger Aaron on your
team well we overcame it you
know we we we
persevered um now like last time we had
you on um I talked about a about your
involvement in big brother but looking
back on it there there wasn't any
real uh like discussion of how you found
big brother I wonder if like if there
was uh like a kind of um a synopsis of
like graduating high school in Tennessee
moving out to like what happened between
graduating high school and and ing big
brother I I wasn't you know I moved out
to become an actor but and I'd taken
some classes and I went to the amican
American Academy of dramatic arts for
like six
weeks um but I was kind of
just spinning my
wheels and then my then girlfriend got
pregnant I'm like I I need to do
something something and so friend of
mine got me a job writing for a couple
of magazines I started writing for
magazines uh I lived next door to an
Antoine Fuqua the director and he got me
a he sent me to a casting director who
got me a commercial agent so I was just
had all these sticks in the fire and one
day I show up on the set of Spike Jones
was helping Jake Fogle Nest I guess he
was co-directing a video with Jake fogl
Nest uh for
wax
and I remember it was the it it's
unfortunate but it was on the day the
Oklahoma City bomb bombing happened
because that was going people told me on
set and Jeff that's the first time I met
Jeff he was in the video and uh Jeff T
yeah yeah
and I told him I wrote he's like oh you
got to come by and check out the
magazine and I didn't even get to be in
the video I had to go to wait on tables
you know so I was like ah and and then I
don't know how much time passed before I
went down
to uh down south to see uh Jeff at was
World Industries okay he wasn't even at
Flint yet right and I walked around he
gave me a tour and I think it was a
little bit over a year or so or maybe
longer before I got the
idea maybe a couple years before I got
the idea to do the self-defense
equipment he was the only magazine that
would support me and helping me buy the
stun gun taser gun and because I had no
money I blew all the money I had my mom
gave me 300 bucks for Christmas and I
got the cheapest bulletproof vest they
had and then I was sunk right so I
needed support from taine and he gave it
to me did you not um Pitch the
self-defense I idea to like Howard Stern
and the talk shows and yeah yeah I I
faxed my idea to Howard
Stern and like pretty far and wide to
like everywhere that could possibly host
it oh yeah like I pitched it to details
magazine like everyone you can think of
and almost across the board people like
the idea but they kind of wanted to
treat it as a negative pickup they
didn't they like when you're done with
it bring it to us
we can't be a part of it until then and
but I don't think I didn't hear back
from Stern but much later he goes I just
thought you were some nut you know which
that's fair you know around the same
time I was pitching to Howard Stern that
I would come and douse my entire body
with rubbing alcohol be set on fire and
there in my boxer shorts and do back
flips like and uh I they didn't want
that either jeez would you imagine that
[__]
what what kind of uh what kind of
Articles were you writing when you were
writing articles um I I like uh you know
I I love hunterz Thompson so a lot of
participatory journalism type stuff I'd
go somewhere or do something and write
about it in freelance you'd submit it to
different magazines all over yeah and as
you were writing you were getting
commercial gigs too right luckily I
started well my first year I started
auditioning for commercials full year
not one call back
and then my next year I got like 12
commercials and uh I didn't think you
did that
anymore it's just water bro oh
okay so yeah I was very lucky cuz I had
a kid then and and that that's how you
met Preston you guys were deliver like
uh because we were talking about you
know some of the worst jobs that you
know people had Preston I think had some
of the worst jobs
um one of his jobs he worked at a uh
waste disposal
place and there was a screen that caught
all the condoms and tampons and
everything and he had to squeegee that
screen that was his job I'm like you win
Preston did I did you not meet Preston
on a commercial audition it wasn't it
was the no I
I met Preston through friends I think
through Beautiful Jason oh yeah and
through that group is how I first met
Preston but when the show we were
getting the show for Jackass he was also
my then wife had a jewelry line and we
need people to like make the jewelry and
bag it and tag it and Preston was
sitting on the couch bagging and tagging
the jewelry along with myself and
whoever else we could find nice I'm like
hey you want to be on a show he's like
sure what came what came first Jackass
or the offer to do stunts on Saturday
Night Live um jackass came first and
right as we were getting ready
to go make the pilot cuz the deal took
forever took over a year for the deal to
get done for Jackass what made it so
slow I don't know you have to talk to
the lawyers forever they're going to
have to have the
yeah um
so but at the 11th
hour I got the offer from Saturday Night
Live and I went to the Beverly Hills
Hotel and met Lauren Michaels in the
Polo Lounge which incidentally is where
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas started
out Hunter as Thompson's novel so I'm it
was another connection to Hunter and God
it was it was you know I was going to
get five minutes on the show to do
like a stunt or a prank every
week and uh and for a guy who was
waiting tables and suddenly I I got this
pilot I'm about to shoot and then
Saturday Night Live wants me to do
something
and it was a lot you know because it's
like everything could fail I could make
the wrong decision but I
just thought God I'm just going to bet
on myself and my friends cuz on SNL I
would have been lucky to be on SNL but I
wouldn't have any
control there is a lot to be said for
not letting other people control your
stuff and wow is it important not to let
other people control your private
information and that's why
nordvpn is so important it stops people
from snooping into all your bank account
information all your private stuff it
keeps you safe and and it allows you to
enjoy stuff as if you were in other
countries why because it changes your
location online doesn't let anybody know
what you're up to or where you are and
it opens up all kinds of entertainment
so it just pays for itself
nordvpn and W do they have a huge deal
for you guys I'm talking about a major
discount if you go to
nordvpn.com
steo that's n o D
vpn.com steo for huge savings plus four
additional free months on your 2-year
plan and get this there's nothing to
lose because you've got a 30-day
risk-free money back guarantee if you
don't love it then get your money back
you got nothing to lose except for all
of your private information everything
in your bank accounts if you don't take
this step to protect yourself by going
going to
nordvpn.com
ssto now let's get back to
it you know right
and you know and like jackass is big on
tone
and if I'm not controlling the tone
along with you know Jeff and Spike it's
I don't know I I just bet on myself and
it could have been a big failure I know
we tried our best but it succeeded
yeah it's it's really interesting I
would think that a lot of people would
have no idea that Saturday Night Live
offered that to you and what it would
have looked like I mean it would have
felt like a kind of a non Secor maybe
you know like something that just didn't
quite fit in with everything else and
most people serving tables would have
dropped what they're doing right away
went on Saturday night life for sure
yeah I remember when the uh uh jackass
pilot was was coming
together um I had an offer to be in a
a music video some kind of video project
for the band Offspring and they were
like oh no I was like yeah I got I got
you know and and they were like no do it
do it for us you can't do this and that
and I was like H I think I'm going to go
with the Spike Jones project what you
what you couldn't do an offspring video
and jackass don't know like there was
something or other like it was uh
whoever was in charge at the time
whoever I was talking to was a little
bit uh bullheaded about it to say the
least and ever since then whenever
Offspring has come on the radio or
anything like that I'm like turn it I
just
can't is that why yeah wait because it
reminds you of that situation or
because I I'm not saying there's anybody
in the band I don't even remember who I
was talking to but I didn't like the way
that they they spoke to
me oh my go I thought you just were so
annoyed at the like tone of their music
that you're like turn this every time it
comes on you're like turn that [__]
[__]
off but it's because it reminds you of
just a resentment it's just all of it
it's all of it oh my that would all make
sense yeah not one to hold the
grudge a man so funny you can't even
look at this on the screen right here
yeah I mean like like I I I don't get
what a lot of the stuff that I hear in
their songs too just kind of it all just
I don't know look at you're getting
uncomfortable I am well I remember like
when we were about to do the pilot where
for Jackass I was meeting with Jonas
aerin who was doing like this punk rock
he was trying to put put together this
punk rock circus I was like Jonas you
got to meet my friend steo like he's a
clown he's very good you know we're
about to do this pilot but I don't you
know I don't think it's going to go
anywhere really so like it would be
great for you to get sto in your circus
I was just trying to get you a gig cuz I
thought ours was going to go yeah well I
appreciate that I remember when when I
first met you in person was December
30th of
1999 Jesus was the day before
stalker it was the day
before day before New Year's the big Y2K
and
i' had flown myself out to California to
do my stilt stunt with the stilt costume
on fire and the unicyclist and the
skateboarder jumping off the roof of the
house over my head through the Fireball
and uh I thought I was trying to shoot a
cover for Big Brother magazine but when
I got out there you know here's
Knoxville and traine I forget if it was
Ballard or you know but every and traine
said now that you're here and I can tell
you we're not just shooting this for for
the magazine we're actually shooting
this for a pilot for uh for MTV and
jackass wasn't even the name it was just
kind of an Untitled Untitled you know
pilot for MTV and you guys had no idea
what it even was I remember before my
stilt stunt like uh you and I sat down
on uh like a couple bales of hay in the
back of this house and like you kind of
interviewed me we didn't know of like if
uh if it was going to be like an
interview the subject kind of a thing
before the bit maybe you guys were
toying around with the idea of it was
going to be like a talk show desk kind
of a thing cutting to throwing to Clips
but It ultimately it just ended up being
like okay forget about a format just
make it well we had the we had the call
a spike we're like do it is there a
sitting behind the desk portion of the
show or this or that and he's like you
guys are already doing the show just
make it like the Big Brother videos yeah
oh yeah that's that's where we're going
with it um what was your first
impression of Steve when you first met
him uh he was very
excitable um and uh I mean I can be a
lot but steo could be a lot especially
when you were using um
and yeah I
remember when like we the on the show it
was like you
were not that wasn't drinking and doing
pills we both we both were but like you
and I are always going opposite
directions you
know I I I that's a very kind way to put
it no no but it's like you were like you
just wanted to get smashed yeah and I
was just wanting to go to the bar and
you know yeah and have eight get
distracted with women or something
yeah I wanted to draw attention to
myself and you wanted to kind of duck
out of yeah the the attention and I was
just a lot I I I I was a lot um but you
also knew that you were a lot it's not
like and that's that that goes a long
way social awareness of like knowing
people are getting uncomfortable yeah he
at that time he couldn't do anything
about it I mean he knew he was aive but
he he couldn't calm himself down but
then it's just like you just learned
like that's how he is he knows it and
you you just love him you know the uh
there are times I remember just being
like AR like I remember multiple times
where uh you like not subtly not
slightly like just put like pills in in
my food or you know oh yeah
like let me just stick two Xanax bars in
sto's sandwich right now blatantly like
he knows they're there but just make him
eat these two danx bars just to try to
get him to come down a couple notches
and even that wouldn't do it my one of
my favorite moves with steo I walk up to
him and I stomp on his foot he go ah and
then I pop his anex in his
mouth yeah that's amazing I think you
learned to stop giving me Aderall pills
but this anex really didn't work either
you know it's just
like yeah yeah you don't strike me as
somebody that ever said like no no no
I've had too much like you probably just
down to go I was just gnarly and I think
that that over the years since then um I
like I I'm very happy to have been have
become an easier guy to be around oh
yeah yeah and and hopefully I have too
because like I I I had a a long way to
go in that area
um
just feel feeling like you like
sometimes you always need to be on and
causing as much chaos as possible cuz
that's what we did for a living and then
it's like and then yeah for sure but you
know like I was telling the guys this
before that uh you know for all the
people you know
like the jackass is so loved and what
people always say about it is you know
that how the the camaraderie between all
the guys just really reads you know you
can tell that everybody says you can
tell you guys just love each other so
much and that's what makes it work this
great chemistry and I I don't disagree
with that at all but like I was telling
the guys it kind of hurts my heart that
we don't like really get together for
dinner like very often at all you know
like and like and and I feel like it's
just uh it's so beautiful that we've had
this relationship for decades now that
we've here we are growing old together
and uh you know I want we're growing old
together we've become like more mature
better adjusted versions of ourselves
and I want us to be able to spend more
time and have more of a relationship
yeah yeah I I could do better in that
department for sure because I
never I never like I just like being
home with the kids and Emily and our
lousy dog bucket yeah um
and and I don't want to say that we've
not had a a great relationship because
we have and uh you know I brought my
my uh limited edition numbered print aie
Osborne oh you finally took the prize
tag off of it for years he just had the
picture on his wall with the prize tag
next to it well he said even before that
he just put tape on the wall and had it
hanging up in this the year I think was
uh 2005 or 2006 nox says hey man I you
know I got you something and I to go
pick it up at this address so I go into
this place it was kind of a non-descript
store I didn't even really know what it
was and I said hey you got something for
me and they they hand me this big uh
flat brown paper bag and I pull out of
it into this print of Aussie osbor oh
wow because aie was my hero I always
said like man I want a party like Aussie
he was so out of control such a maniac
and I want to like be that and uh pulled
it out I like oh this is cool and then I
look in the bag and there's the receipt
and and the receipt shows that the price
of the print was more than
$1,500 I was like Wow and it says right
on there like it's it's 21 of 90 in
existence this picture and I didn't even
frame it for you hey steo go pick up
your gift oh come on let's face it
wrapping gifts is just a waste of paper
but the biggest waste of paper is when
you smear poop poop all over your own
butthole with toilet paper it's so
stupid I can't believe it I mean come on
when's everybody going to start washing
their buttholes with Beday from hello
tushi I've been doing it for years it's
my favorite product I've ever been
introduced to by this podcast I love my
bedet from Hello tushy and wow do they
have a special deal for you man so that
you too can conveniently twist a dial
and feel that refreshing blast just
washing your butthole man you've got to
try it and if you go to hellotushy.com
steo and use the promo code steo for a
limited time you will get 15% off your
first bedet order and that applies to
every bedet that they have plus free
shipping you can't beat it man it's the
best product I've ever promoted and this
deal is for for a limited time only so
go to hellotushy.com
sto and use the promo code steo by the
way there's not a better holiday gift
out there so jump on it and let's get
back to
it what an
Asser I I I brought it home to my
apartment at the time just grabbed a
piece of tape and just stuck it with no
frame I I just taped the the the print
to the wall and then right next to it I
taped the receipt that said, 1500 bucks
the and then like shortly thereafter I
was on MTV Cribs and like like
highlighted it and like bragged about it
like here's the print here's the receipt
so funny and you know what's it became
like such a more beautiful thing because
I I I went on to learn that that picture
is was taken in
1974 of Aussie Osborne and it was taken
in London England and I was born in 1974
in London England like that photo was
snapped as I was yeah I knew
that the whole time but yeah just I mean
there's been things like that over the
years that that's M Rock right yeah and
he just passed away yeah well speaking
of artwork yeah speaking of artwork
wow Aussie Osborne artwork yeah I mean
we we have uh we decided that we should
do another collab that people can be
excited about yes and uh we are just in
introducing to the world our new
skateboard design yes I'm really psyched
on this one I was psyched on the last
one but this one is uh you know from a
really
great uh artist Todd
brr a legend in in in art and
particularly skateboard art and and the
first skateboard collab the that we did
like I I kind of uh pulled it together
made it happen steered the ship and this
time
you were the kind of creative engine
behind it and so it's kind of cool like
I I I drummed up the first one you
drummed up the second one yeah yeah no I
mean I was more the producer on it you
know uh just trying to get it done and
going back and forth between you and and
Todd and yeah it was uh I'm really
psyched with how the first one was the
Johnny O is this the Johnny O or the uh
the um we're calling this Johnny 2.0
oh wow I think
so and and here I
am signing for the very first time here
you go I think in Black okay sure all
right where where where's a good place
to sign you're you're a pro at this uh I
don't know I kind of think go that way
maybe go this way I mean I don't know
you tell you tell me but let's not let's
not
uh water down our fascinating
conversation oh yeah yeah here we
go
don't there it is now are one of you
guys going to keep that first one or are
you going to give that one put that for
sale on the website already I uh I don't
I don't know I'm not sure but in any
case it's exciting the first one was uh
was great the the first one I mean
they're going on eBay for more than 600
bucks sheesh it's uh it's unbeliev able
so these things have proven to increase
in value and I expect that this one will
be uh even more the case because I don't
think that we're trying to push this one
for very long yeah and and Todd is an
amazing artist so yeah and and I love
that I love that you reached out to do
that again yeah um I I appreciate that
uh okay so on this art for people just
listening you are holding a cattle prod
yes which is something that is near and
dear to your heart yes and we in this
very van heard Eric Andre really really
butt hurt about
you very sensitive yeah uh um I mean we
all love Eric Andre and and yes he's
also very sensitive so I just wonder if
um you know he described uh he quit the
show he came back to the show he
couldn't stand it it was too much like
you know you were terrorizing him if you
could characterize the experience with
uh with d he he quit the show three
times in the first seven days you know
the show is called prank panel yeah
yeah and
um yeah it was very traumatic for him
starting out because I thought you know
we're going to go with each other and uh
I went at him and I think it came down
to he's not he's used to being the
hammer and not the
nail
and it to be the nail it just kind of
threw him back on his heels uh but yeah
I mean finally the on the third time he
quit he was like he was done for good
yeah he and so like kimel's having to
call me like the first time he quit I
was in Minnesota with Emily seeing her
parents he's like you got to call me and
I call he's like er quit I'm like what
cuz he had pranked me that Friday what
does that look like when he pranks you
it didn't go so good uh he brought out a
stun wand and hit me with it okay see I
think you guys were kind of maybe
Loosely interchanging the idea of prank
with assault I don't think yeah I don't
no I don't think
that's like is it assault when I go
after you guys on jackass I mean
certainly not on jackass but I think
that uh like Eric Andre it's a prank
yeah assault it takes it into like whoa
we're not there like this is all for
humor um right understood and I think
that when I say assault that's obviously
not my take on it I think that that was
the oh yeah no that was running through
his mind yeah yeah yeah I'm like what
that's that's not the game we're playing
right um but of course uh I got it we
got to come back and I just we just
couldn't prank each other anymore the
rest of the season or I couldn't prank
him and uh was fine uh and overall it
was a good experience with the show are
you guys going to do any more uh yeah it
was a good experience it was hard it was
very hard because when we're pranking on
jackass you you you set up the prank and
run people through all day long till you
get the desired reaction and on this
you've only got one Mark you only got
one Mark you know you're pranking
someone's sister brother and but pretty
early on I'm like we're going to have to
bring in other practice marks to have
something to air if it goes wrong right
so that happened a few times and thank
God we had practice marks cuz you even
if on you're doing pranks you're not
going to go 20 for 20 and we had to get
20 of those mhm
so first we were going to do like 30
pranks to get 20 but by the end of the
year we had to the money ran out we had
to go 20 for 20 so it was tough but I
think we did pretty good some of the
pranks we pulled off
were like as epic as anything we had
done on jackass like two or three of
them um so yeah the clown one the clown
one did you see ever see the clown one
you know I I
saw like I didn't see the whole episode
I just saw like bits of it well you
gotta watch the clown one I know you
told me about that and I've been
terrible you know like I I I love you so
much and and I've
uh
I I've I've never seen like your your
acting in in movies it's a weird thing
and it's almost like a a streak that
like i' I've just kept pres preserved
that like from ages and ages and ages go
I was able to say I've never watched a
Johnny Knox movie that I wasn't
in and and uh and and then recently it
uh it occurred to me because I you know
I kept the streak alive and I thought
well thank
you you shouldn't have I know but but
now I think like like I said you're
missing out because there's that movie
uh alen Parson project or what's the
movie called Grand Theft Parson Grand
Theft s yeah that I I love that movie
well thanks I I wasn't too happy with my
performance and that and that was very
early on but there there have been some
that uh I would like you to watch steo I
I would I'm GNA I'm going to I'm going
to the the idea of not having senior
movies is silly and uh it it struck me
as and a little selfish he's like if I
don't got a piece of the back end I
ain't watching he's there no no I'm
sorry wait hold on I I I I watched Bad
Grandpa and it was genius oh okay well
little taste yeah yeah there was a
little taste yeah did have a little
taste
was you got a taste yeah okay so what
what noox means by a little taste I
wasn't in the movie on screen but I did
have a little taste in the back end and
that was a generous thing because you
guys said since uh it was under the
jackass Banner that uh the jackass guys
and when he was doing that you were
originally
bummed if I'm honest I was bummed but
you know what I'm bummed about today is
people destroying the world making
crappy products and exploiting the
people who made them I'm talking about
crappy clothes okay and that's why I'm
so hyped about outerknown my bro Kelly
Slater started this company for a better
Planet man come on they use organic and
recycled material
and they're made in Fair Trade factories
where people are treated nicely and it's
all way better for the world and it
looks way cooler when you wear it so
they've got a killer deal for you if you
go to outerknown.com steo and use the
promo code steo then all of my friends
and followers enjoy 25% off their entire
order that is a massive discount you
should jump on this immediately by going
to outerknown.com that's o u t r k n o w
n.com steo and use the promo code steo
for that massive 25% off your entire
order hop on it and let's get back to it
because well here's here's the thing
here's the thing and and uh I may have
had a conversation with somebody in a
different setting who said that uh that
all Paramount one wanted was more
jackass but all Knoxville wanted was
like uh like to to do real movies like
you know he like yeah the jackass is
great but I want to preserve the Legacy
and and really what I want is to be like
a you know movies so so this guy says I
kind of lied to my bosses saying you
know I'm gonna get Knoxville to do Jacks
4 but really what they were talking
about was bad grandpa and so the Trap
the the tragedy of it for me was that
that it came out on the internet and the
story was Paramount Pictures has bought
jackass 4.com jackass for movie.com Jack
and and I was like wait like they're
doing this and that was uh what it was
was bad grandpa but they initially
snatched up all the jackass Ford thing
and I think it was a way that the Bad
Grandpa was a way to uh to get Pam happy
they had more jackass and get you happy
that you had like more of a like a movie
situation this was how it was described
to me yeah I don't I someone said they
were trying to get me to do jackass 4
and we did Jack we did Bad Grandpa
instead they not this the Paramount
wanted jackass 4 and so that so
Paramount was told you guys are gonna
get jackass 4 you wanted no Paramount
was never ever told that ever like we
decide like at the last second and then
we call up here hey we we'd like to do
another one well then I've been lied to
yeah that time you were so bummed for
nothing well I mean it was like I saw
the stories about they bought up jackass
4.com and they probably did but that was
like I never promised them that was in
two 2011 or 12 we did B Grandpa
something um it it was uh
2012 yeah 2012 when we went to bad we
went to Paramount to pitch two
films the day we pitched Bad Grandpa
and we pitched uh a movie with Broken
Lizard the Broken Lizard guys where
Willie was going to play Willie Nelson
was going to play this ass kicking
karate guy so you get to see Willie
Nelson kick ass and we were
praying they bought that one Jeff and I
are like I we hope they don't pick Bad
Grandpa because that's going to be a
[__] nightmare to pull off you know
the whole movie's dead predicated on
like people
reacting that's the last thing we wanted
and we went in there and pitched and
then they said we want to do Bad Grandpa
and we're
like I think we look like we've been
punched in the stomach and we came out
of there walking out of Paramount
someone just bought a movie from us it
was like a death in the family
we were so bummed really wow the actual
process of shooting it too was uh like
like with you and Jeff like was it I
wasn't there but were you guys kind of
at odds with each other
creatively um it was very it was
incredibly difficult that film because
like I said it's all predicated on
people reacting and we had a
story and I think we were it was very
stressful so yeah there was a little
tension between Jeff and I at times on
that
film just because it was it was
incredibly difficult well right and when
you say predicated on reactions what you
mean is the the film was comprised like
exclusively of hidden camera footage
very very little scripted filler to to
drive it along and like the the fact
that you did that unbelievably
impressive but like what you get one
thing and then now you got to bring go
back to the drawing board like oh well
we thought the story was going this way
but what we got is this so now we got to
kind of yeah I mean we the first couple
of trips like we had a loose narrative
like where the story was going to begin
and
end but I would be doing these pranks on
the first couple of trips and I didn't
know where I was in the story right so I
don't know what to push along or to say
or and finally we came home after we'
been getting great stuff
but we didn't know where we were in the
story and Spike
finally he goes hey I read your guys
treatment that you wrote up that's not a
story he's like we got to shut down and
just work on the the story either the
whole month of November I maybe the
whole month of November and we did and
he came by and he really hashed out the
story with this not too much not too
much storye simple very simple
but it really changed everything because
when we went back out on the road the
following January next
year I knew exactly where I was in the
story and what I needed to do and what I
could do and uh yeah it was it was uh
I'm I'm so happy we did it now and you
know like before we shot that first
prank in the movie I was still in my re
I was really bummed and I was just focus
it on I was just like telling myself oh
it's going to suck to sit in the yeah
the this get the makeup done for three
three and a half hours every day and and
that was not actually what was
happening I mean it took that long but I
was more scared about failing and
thinking I'm going to shoot this for 3
months and have to turn it into a
jackass cuz we're not going to get
anything but after the very first prank
we did it went
good didn't make it the movie but it
went good and all that stress went away
and I felt like I I think we got this i
got this yeah is it more stressful
shooting the reaction stuff than say
knowing you're going to get hit by a
bull it's different a different kind of
stress yeah yeah
um I I get more stress for stunts
watching them do something
dangerous uh of course I get nervous
myself but I just don't like watching
them when it gets too big to do anything
too big yeah it's uh I remember my uh
stunt where I laid down in the rocket
engine fuel and the guys lit it and I
ended up burned up that wasn't even a
stunt that was like a cry for help I I
thought you know it was it's like I
called you and I'm like I don't yeah
well I remember like I it it there's a
lot of other stuff that went along with
that prank and I don't know how much you
want to get into that but you were in a
kind of a way at that time that that
actually sent me into a way kind of but
yeah I was I was it was uh there days we
had a little talk after I saw that video
yeah yeah it was a it was a tough one
but at the same time like like like on
my new bucket list special where I get
the the 4 in needle in my spine and I'm
paralyzed and the guys are like you know
like testing how paralyzed I am with
paintballs and tasers and flames and
like I that's a times that's a bad
situation to be in for us because it's
like here we are he's paralyzed from the
waist down and like the whole bit is
relying on us seeing if his legs are
dead and so
like we have to do it because it's the
bit it's it you know we went big for it
and while I'm doing it in my head I'm
thinking like okay if he dies and this
footage goes before a judge the judge is
like I'm sorry you guys did what you
know so like producing this
me and it's like but if we don't do it
right we don't torture you on the ground
you're going to be done and be like dude
I I did all this for nothing and then if
we did do it and you something did
happen to you I'm sitting there lighting
your feet on fire shooting you up with
the [__] paintball or it was in my
head I'm thinking like being in front of
a grand jury like I'm [__] well you're
burying the lead too because what we
didn't expect was that as I'm laying
there on the ground that my whole like
respiratory system seems to be shutting
down I can't feel like any indication
that I'm able to breathe for me to draw
enough breath to tell you guys that I
was having trouble breathing was like
difficult well and then I remember we
talk a [__] nightmare and at that
point did like I guess you had Medical
attension on the set kind of yeah kind
of kind of I mean he was the doctor was
appropriately dressed up as a clown he
was the anesthesiologist I guess uh like
I'm not even going to be specific
but okay he used my old
dealer but the thing is before was he a
doctor uh he was Medical Professional
yes he was he was absolutely a medical
professional a doctor yes okay but
here's the [__] up thing cuz we we had
a meeting with Dr Drew before this and
Dr Drew is like you know it was Dr
Drew I reached out to Dr Drew and ran
the idea by him oh poor Dr Drew and he
said he said well it's safe but you'll
know it's going bad if the medicine goes
upwards into your diaphragm and you
can't breathe so he's saying he says
really watch out if you find yourself
becoming paralyzed above the waist
because sometimes the stuff can back up
and then you're gonna have your systems
shutting down and and that's bad and
that seemed to be precisely what was
happening during the bit how far were
you numb I couldn't feel I couldn't feel
my chest at all I could not tell that I
was able to did they get you to the
hospital then no no they never got me to
the hospital the the clown doctor was
like it's okay you're fine you know and
like and like the
uh little horn it it was it was just
like it was just very intense and in
that circumstance here like these guys
their job is to like do all this
terrible stuff to me so that's kind of
what what was going on but by the end of
it this this happened in August in the
baking sun and like I can't feel what's
going on so maybe I'm being burned up
they carry me over and lay me down in
the concrete and I just start sobbing I
just start sobbing and the the the clown
doctor is is confused as to what's going
and my and through my tears I say the
bar for my stunts is so high and my
and we [__] raised it man and it was
just these tears of joy because I had
done something that was like far in away
more like just [__] up and like you
know I remember offering the bit to you
for for Jack guys and you're were like
hey buddy you know like we can't like
break the law for for a movie well I
just didn't want I what I was having
trouble with was I don't want to
anesthetize you you being being you know
your history with drugs an epidural is
ways down so that would that actually
wasn't a concern it was just like I
don't know I
just a [__] up situation [__] up
situation and that was the beauty of it
and and I know that when that when you
saw the footage you were like hey man
like that to me is kind of dark and and
like in my view uh I agree it's kind of
dark and and I would say that man like
watching you
snoring on the ground after the bull
flips you into your head also
dark like in a lot of ways our darkest
moments are like the magic of it you
know and and so I just love it is that
one you would never do again oh the
epidural yeah man there's there are
things that could be done with an
epidural but like but it's not on my
list well if if you done it you done it
you know it's like you want to retire
epidurals um I don't know I don't know
but I think that that uh someone other
than me because of my history with drugs
there should be a tranquilizer dart foot
race yeah the tranquilizer dart is
different because it's going to go into
your muscle well we always wanted to do
that idea um but I think it's tough to
when the dark goes in it absorbs through
the muscle well you don't want the to
pump a bunch of air into a vein or
something yeah then you're you have bits
locked away in a vault that you guys
have never done that well he's got you
got books yeah there's a lot a lot
there's a lot of stuff that we haven't
gotten to yeah well I bought out jackass
5.com it's crazy how often people ask me
so are you guys going to do another one
you know I we could be on jackass 27
they'll be like so what's up with 28 for
sure yeah yeah um but uh
my my answer is always I just can't
imagine it happening but don't take my
word for it because I would have said
the same thing about a jackass 4 for for
10 years to go by with no jackass and
all of a sudden you reach out and say
guys I'm ready to go again I I know
that's happened on the last two
like like on Jack S4 I started getting
that Twitchy feeling that I wanted to do
it again and then we were around 200
8ish or 9ish we had a office over Office
Sunset yeah for Jackass world yeah and I
and I just started watching so much Tom
and Jerry again and I started getting
that feeling and well that's what
inspired you Tom and Jerry well I just
knew that I was trying to think of ideas
right I knew that I wanted to do another
one so I was watching and I and I
thought Jeff would like because we had a
desk right across from each other and I
think he would see Tom and Jerry and
he's like he would put two and two
together finally I said I wanted to do
another one and he was so shocked a lot
of everyone was shocked on that one too
was it your idea for the new cast was
that was it your idea for the new cast
uh I I I think it was a
collective idea Collective meaning
between you Jeff and
Spike yeah I think we just talked and
we're like it would be good to bring on
some fresh blood because right it might
be tonally weird to watch a bunch of old
guys do it you know it could be sweaty
yeah
so that was the word yeah I want to
bring up uh and and apologize the the
movie I was talking about was Grand
wasn't Grand Theft Parsons I'm really
bad at movies and and and names and
remembering things but it was the one
where you played uh a boyfriend a drug
dealing boyfriend and it was based on a
true story oh small apartments no it was
it was on Netflix and uh it's oh oh that
was with and the girl falls in love with
the cop and the cop was dirty and yeah
yeah yeah you played your role in that
was awesome and I and I I I'm meaning to
ask like how did you get involved in
that cuz that's a movie based on a true
story yes I it's above suspicion Amilia
Clark yeah I was in that with her that
was really good Philip no is a great
director and I auditioned for that
and I'm and usually if I have to
audition I never get it because I'm
terrible at auditioning I just it's
too I get too inside my head right I
can't relax and I'm too inside my head
but that one like I was relaxed and did
what I needed to do and uh we shot that
in Kentucky
about 2 hours 3 2 and a half hours from
where I was born so it was
nice um yeah if people get a chance to
see that it it that that's a it it was a
good movie yeah that's one of the ones
I'm like I thought that usually like I I
get sweaty watching myself I'm like Oh I
thought okay I did all I did pretty good
in that one I did
uh I did a pretty good job in that one I
was going to say before that I had an
idea for a YouTube video a Johnny
Knoxville movie
Marathon I'm going to watch them all and
then like uh like react you know people
make reaction videos and and I I I put
the idea aside I didn't think to pursue
it because I wouldn't want it to like
make it seem like you know disparaging
or anything but I also would love to
have the experience and and kind I think
that there could be an idea there yeah
you might want to space it out I don't
know that's something you do over a
weekend start with Walking Tall okay I
wonder with uh is it it the way that
society's changed and you know gone woke
and so sensitive like is the ringer a
movie that you see as problematic in any
in any way no not at all we made that
movie with the support of the Special
Olympics and they wanted us to push the
comedy and push push uh the boundaries
um
because you know our fan base is like
who we're trying to get the word out
to
um and they they they were fully on
board and unfortunately I think I'm very
proud of that movie and unfortunately I
think people heard the synopsis that I
was going to fake like yeah uh I was
pretend to have a disability yeah and so
I can enter the Special
Olympics and I think people heard the
premise and they're like oh that's
that's not for us but it's actually a
very uh sweet movie and I made so many
friends on that I mean you've met Eddie
and John Taylor yeah uh
so all right so that's so the Ringer's
first step on my Marathon yeah I I I'm
really proud it's one of my favorite
films okay great I love that movie um
you guys are neighbors yeah uh I bought
a ranch in Tennessee I don't want to uh
really like put it on blast for exactly
where where it's at but uh I think that
we actually just learned today we own
properties pretty near to each other oh
well I I I well you're kind of kind of
giving it away
okay okay we all they have to do is look
that up right I I me but I sold my
property the John Cash yeah yeah yeah I
sold it uh years ago okay but um I mean
whatever dude I'm I mean I think you
even on a past podcast you even said
where it was yeah and I it's like you're
driving around there with sto.com on the
side of your van it's like people know
he has like a bat signal that says steo
up yeah okay uh let me ask you this um
you whenever we text it always seems to
be that you're in the gym and when uh
whenever I go to go get CPAP equipment
for my CPAP machine like the little CPAP
store is adjoined to the gym that you go
to yeah so it's just nox was in the gym
he's in the gym like all the time like
what are you training
for man I just have to like exercise
because I've had so much trouble with my
back okay and so I have to do certain
things to keep my back you know from
seizing up and also I'm an incredibly
vain person right okay so uh um but I
was just wondering maybe you were like
uh hitting the bags getting oh no I am I
just started uh doing boxing lessons
again too oh right yeah so that's
training for a big
fight that's funny
that's
funny yeah I really got to get in shape
for that
one no I just wanted to I just wanted to
train again it's a lot of fun uh so um
you uh I've always been like very
careful um to to not be
chubby yes yes like is that something
you have to put effort into because with
me I'm like a yo-yo diet like I'm out of
control with food and then I'm like I
hit a rock bottom and then I just go the
other way and then I get like kind of
back in in reasonable shape and then I
think I'm good and then I start eating
like an [__] again yeah yeah I you
know my both my parents gained weight as
they got older and I I I just didn't
want
to
gain uh that much weight as I got older
cuz it's just all kinds of health
problems yeah so yeah I've always very
been very conscious of my weight and
exercising and yeah I I flip-flop about
5 to n lbs yeah I've never seen you fat
in my
life I was a little I I was a little
uh
rubenesque this time last Christmas cuz
we've been
shooting uh
for a few months and I was there every
day right and just eating whatever the
craft Services really screws you
craft Services is like just the the
snack setup they they have just like the
greatest snacks just a bunch of tables
covered in easy food to just eat so like
we start movies and everybody's been
like training eating sensibly they're
looking their best maybe the first week
even the guys have their shirts off but
that craft service table just screws you
as the production goes on yeah it does
but like we never had craft service on
the first couple of movies did we um I
remember like the third movie like that
first day when uh like the um the uh
with the the above ground pool the
Preston L he made that D that I saw that
bit like uh recently so good and like we
all had our shirts off that was the
first week of filming oh
yeah that and because we had a 3D crew
with us and the crew got much bigger on
the third one so like we got to have
craft uh craft service cuz that's what
people who are in the business are used
to yeah and uh yeah I don't cuz I don't
remember one on the first couple yeah
the the first everyone was so high I
don't think they'd be eating
anyway yeah the first movie you had the
the cocaine Buffet crafty service yeah
yeah something that that I've been
thinking about lately and I remember us
doing it I don't remember it ever coming
out but you talking about the bummer no
no no no no
no no no are we allowed to talk about
that yet no we're not talking about and
apologies for for all the times I tried
to bully you into it um lately I've been
thinking about uh helium balloons I just
can't you know I know it's been done I
know that we even did it the idea was
like uh I think we sent up bam with a
bunch of helium balloons and he was
supposed to shoot the but to come back
down well as written I think I wrote the
idea is to
get one of those big weather balloons
and walk up behind somebody with uh what
do you call those things a carabiner a
carabiner and just pop it on their belt
and watch them float away yeah but then
it's like that's problematic because
they [__] go to the atmosphere yeah
yeah yeah yeah and even if we do it over
water so I'm so sorry I seem to recall
that at uh the team pain compound in
Orlando I I have a memory I think it was
bam flying around with helium balloons
maybe I I'm just we did we did uh we did
do that
but he knew he was going up
and we had to put a tether on the
balloon too oh okay that was the only
way the insurance would allow us to do
it if we had a tether to the balloon
which which defeats the whole [__]
purpose of the idea so we still like I
don't know we'll still try it and we
tried it and he took a BB gun up and
shot himself down
but the reason it wasn't in was because
he knew it was happening and there was a
tether and so without a
tether it's uh what does a tether do
from the floor there's a tether to the
balloon so it's like can never get away
yeah you know he's leashed to the ground
so he can't go up into the atmosphere
yeah um C because I've just been I've
had that on my mind man like uh to do it
without a tether like I was just
thinking of ways to draw a lot of
attention to myself to to promote my
bucket list special and uh I thought if
I just like was floating with a ton of
helium balloons like um in the right
spot that I might catch some
headlines well didn't someone I don't
know whether it was a a rumor or someone
did it in a lawn chair yeah there were I
I Googled it I Googled it I think it was
in Canada a guy um and I feel like he
got uh arrested or something arrested
for what like International airspace I
don't I don't know I don't know but uh I
mean how
the that doesn't look like awn that
looks like a pro job yeah right like I a
hoarder I don't know like how how to
approach it I just like was thinking of
what's a good way for me to to just do a
big thing and and get a get a lot of uh
yeah I guess I mean did the guy have
a see even a parachute is like a
tether you know it's like it you got to
feels like you got to go for it or you
got to have a BB gun to shoot the
balloons yeah yeah that seems fine like
shoot one at a time like to like
regulate your elevation I I'm going to
keep looking into it I probably
shouldn't put this out there but hey you
know what yeah
I yeah I I mean you can put it out there
if you want I just I think surprising
people is good too yeah that's true
that's true so let's I'm cutting that
too so we're cutting that too we're
really
[__] or is like a that there's a
there's is that a balloon the shape of a
is that a cartoon or they it's Pixar oh
cuz like if you made a big huge balloon
that looked like uh Tain and you flew up
with
that something's there yeah all right
um so uh so the TV show with that you
did today is um just a oneoff thing you
did for yeah what do you have like uh on
the horizon if there's anything that you
want to talk about um well I do my radio
show with my cousin Roger yeah you've
been doing that forever big ass happy
family Jubilee on Outlaw country on
Sirius for we've done way over 500
shows um so we've been doing that a long
time and that's usually the highlight of
my week getting to chat with him for an
hour and play music uh and I have a few
films I'm getting ready to do next year
because I've been off the whole year
because of the strike yeah um so I'm
looking for to that and I I just started
a podcast but it's very premature and uh
so more on that later but what what what
are the movies can you talk about
anything that for next year yeah
n yeah I I don't know cuz like if you
talk about a movie ahead of time and
then it doesn't come out right you're
like oh I I should have kept that under
my hat I shouldn't have brought up life
without dick on Letterman before it was
shot
you can skip that one steo but you might
like the ones that are so bad there okay
but I don't know if it gets to so bad
it's good it may just kind of yeah hover
dude shark NATO that reminds me of
something of legend that uh the bummer
no you were weren't you on
Letterman and like you were up in the
rafters and jumped out and like badly
hurt yourself landing and then sat
through the interview yeah I there was I
think it was my first time on Letterman
and I jumped out of the whatever the
catwalk the rigging yeah yeah and
spraying both my ankles I wonder if that
is there footage of that oh wow there
you can see footage of it and I think
any like a skater could have rolled out
of it but I didn't know I don't know how
to fall so I just went straight down
yeah I mean your lack look
wow your lack of uh ability to fall
correctly makes you the most exciting
professional skate well thank you no I
would do regular movies and the stunt
guys would try to teach me how to fall
I'm like don't you dare I don't want to
learn how to
fall um that's so
great um I wonder uh now like I'm
sensitive to this like uh I don't know
that I could have done it any other way
but when I've been promoting my bucket
list special objectively because I
ejaculate on camera because I've got the
the medical professionals literally on
the camera uh I think I did ejaculate
just a little bit yeah um with the
ejaculation with the the medical
professionals stealing drugs and
administering them and non-medical
settings like there's just a a a good
amount of stuffff that I simply would
never have been able to do for Jackass
yeah that's true and I uh was not
bashful about making that abundantly
clear when I was promoting The Bucket
List special but part of me like uh by
saying you know the stunts that he
couldn't do for Jackass strong selling
point but I just kind of crawling into
your head and imagining you seeing my
bucket list promos I almost feel you
cringing when you see that and I just
want I just want to I I've probably I've
probably seen your promos but yeah we're
we're good steo yeah you know it's like
yeah I just I'm just sensitive to that
because I want to respect you I want to
respect the Legacy and I also want to uh
get well well thank you but uh you know
I I get it you got you got a thing to
promote so yeah and and it's objectively
true too so I feel good about that I
really did push things pretty damn far
yeah whether like we couldn't do it
legally or I like Jeff or I thought
tonally maybe that's not right for us
and so yeah stuff that wouldn't make
jackass and you yeah me you did it yep
um and uh I sent you a a line cut of uh
you know a show like it's I think it's
been you know well over a year since
since I mean it was just a long time ago
was it just a recording show got notes
back to you did okay good oh 100% of the
time I've ever sent you anything for
notes you've always not only taken the
time to to
Really watch it or read it or or
whatever the case may be but really
giving back thoughtful notes oh thank
you and uh I I took all of your notes on
the bucket list very much to heart um I
had still had plenty of touring to do to
to do my best to implement them like in
in some cases I I I did it 100% in other
cases like uh I tried it didn't work the
biggest not they're not all hit
steo but the biggest note was that you
gave me was um to try to be more
conversational in my delivery and and
that inspired me to hire a a speaking
coach oh really yeah not a voice coach
obviously not a voice
coach but a speaking coach and and what
that speaking coach those sessions it uh
man it it felt like therapy
like kind of like trying to chip away it
like what is it that's making me so
stiff and and like like uh there was a
self-consciousness about being on stage
performing live comedy like how do
people want to accept me like and and uh
it just helped so much and that was
totally because of you and I think the
bucket list is way better because of it
oh that's good but I totally understand
that because you're like if I'm doing a
character and I'm big
you're kind of you can hide behind that
right and and they're
not and if something goes wrong they're
it was the character but it's it's
harder just to be
yourself yeah it's it's it's hard to be
in front of a crowd and be yourself and
of course you're going to you know try a
bunch of different way starting out but
the big the biggest thing was with the
the speech coach
the speaking coach um she said in the
the stunt video the vignettes that that
you know are peppered throughout the
performance you're very natural and
loose and conversational the Vette like
and and while you're doing these like
unbelievably crazy things but then when
you're just on the stage like just
talking that it's less natural why what
just be the guy in the clips and that
became my Mantra yeah like I'm just the
guy in the clips yeah you're very funny
and lovable and and facing and and you
know very honest about your feelings in
and the stuff we do is it is it harder
for you to uh do a
movie or or like a a jackass like are
you more comfortable filming a clip on
jackass or like when you're in a a movie
and you have the whole crew looking at
you and you have to rehearse lines
and is there a big difference or is it
uh an
initially uh getting over the camera
took a
while tell me about it well I mean
just I just remember in high school
already said I want to go out to Los
Angeles to be an actor you know I'd
already been very open about that and
someone came to our school to talk
about uh our lunch program and how we
can do it better and it was we had to
talk to people on camera and tell them
and they was like seven of
us and down the line everyone was so
natural and good and when they were like
it's your turn Terror I couldn't think
of anything I just
froze and and it
took uh I moved to LA and I would do
scene study
classes on camera uh Jeremiah Comey he's
a great acting coach and little by
little I was I became less conscious of
the camera but at first it was it's
scary but by the time I got around to
doing
films um I was okay with the camera but
um like when you're doing Walkin tall
were
you uh nervous about the camera no not
at all like I not at all no
you
um no I i' conquered that fear by the
time I was doing that I remember we were
shooting the jackass TV show while you
were filming Walking Tall and part of
your contract for Walking Tall precluded
you from being able to do any dangerous
stunts well I was doing uh big trouble
trouble yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
the one big trouble was like we did
jackass and big trouble was like the
second movie I got but it was a big
movie Renee Russo Tim Allen right right
you're right um Tom seore I had every
seene with Tom
seore and I and then there was like
Stanley Tucci and Dennis finina huge
actors Jason Lee was in it I remember
they flew me down first class
to uh Miami and I was already nervous
cuz I wasn't supposed to do any stunts
and I had a sprained ankle so I'm like
okay if they don't fire me for my acting
they're going to fire me when I get
there for my ankle so I got in first
class and it was great and I was like
this this is terrible because this is
what I'm about to say goodbye to and I
get down to Miami and they pick me up
back when they sent a limo they pick me
up in a limo took me to my hotel room it
was a big Suite I'm like this is even
worse everything they did nice for me
I'm like this is all going away tomorrow
yeah at the table read and and so I I at
the table read every every scenes with
Tom seore I'm sitting across from
Stanley Tucci Dennis finina Renee Russo
Barry son and fell with his directors
down here and I meet seore and he's like
hey how about you be good today I'm like
oh [__] this is terrible and so we start
doing our scene and every line is with
Tom and Tom I give him uh a line and
he's about to say his line he's
like what are you doing with this accent
this what it's terrible and I'm just
like oh oh no you know this is
everything's coming true and I looked
down down at the director and he's kind
of looking at me and I look over people
across from me but I'm like you know
what I felt like Sylvester Stallone and
rhinestone I'm like if I'm going to die
I'm going to die my way so I kept doing
the accent later 30 minutes later I give
him a line he's about to do a line he's
like you're still doing that accent
Barry and he looks at Barry son and Feld
Jesus and Stanley Tui looks over was
like and I thought it was a comment on
me but it wasn't but anyway long story
short
afterwards uh sonel came up it's like
don't don't worry about Tom just keep
doing it exactly the way you're doing it
and it was it was a which made me feel
relieve but I still was nervous and
seore really laid it to me for those
first couple of weeks of the film but I
just thought it was
hilarious it was a story that he was
like really testing me
and then he saw that like I'm pretty
unflappable and pretty easygoing and
then he didn't like when other people
talk to me like I like then I was his so
uh he's he's no longer here so but uh
he's a great actor it was just a pretty
intense relationship we had on our first
trial by fire yeah hey he's still doing
that accent I was like oh god um I
remember that uh yeah it wasn't Walking
Tall it was trouble and you had this
palacial hotel suite and it was in that
hotel suite like on the balcony where
you stapled the jackass across my uh my
butt cheeks oh really yeah and because
you were shooting the movie like you
couldn't do any stunts so like you were
like carrying the dead alligator around
putting the fake baby on the roof of the
car yeah like uh I felt really bad about
that cuz you guys are out there putting
it on the line and I'm like in a hotel
suite in Coconut Grove
and uh I remember um the in that that
palacial hotel suite you had a suitcase
that had uh like more pill bottles than
clothing oh yeah yeah I rattled when I
walked yeah Thompson and uh you know
like it's it's it's pretty incredible
how things were back in those days like
we were just so untethered and uh and
like you just some people can just put
it down you know like like I was not you
know I to really do the makeing the
thing and and you just kind of outgrew
all that the phase yeah yeah and you
know like I I I could
uh I you know kind of saved it more for
the the road and whatnot cuz you know I
had a kid and yeah
can't but uh yeah I uh I don't
know we all we all got very lucky yeah
we've all been very lucky
almost yeah yeah um we can cut this out
but you've never you guys never talked
about and I don't know if I should even
say this but you guys have matching
tattoos oh yeah yeah and my daughter got
this tattoo yeah we got this tattoo do
you want to cut that out um I feel like
there I don't think they were too
worried about it I've seen it before I
think yeah yeah I don't think we're
we're precious about the fact that we
got matching tattoos of the logo on the
can of video head cleaner that we were
huffing and that was it wasn't nitrous
oxide it was video head tape cleaner
how' you guys here to do that like told
you someone told me like no no I
remember this super well um it was it
was Pennsylvania we're shooting jackass
number two and uh they were busy fil
filling up uh like Bam's mom's house
with the fake snow to to ride snow skis
down the uh the stairs like into the the
door like was a snow snow skiing inside
the house was the bit it's taking
forever to set up and uh like you had
just watched a movie about some like
country music legend who was sounds van
yeah yeah sniffing glue and so you are
far less concerned with the the the snow
blowing operation or the skiing than
getting your hands on some airplane
model glue you had you were sending off
like the the the PA to go like to
airplane model stores and come back with
glue and then like we got back from
Pennsylvania and uh you know like I got
a message from you and you said hey um
uh full disclosure I've learned that uh
that a video head cleaner is is much
better like much better than airplane
glue much cleaner buzz you well someone
told me like there's a place on
Hollywood Boulevard you can get nitrous
nitrous oxide check this out Knoxville
hit me up with a note and I'm thinking
oh he's going to tell me to take out the
whole part about huffing video head
cleaner but his note was that when he
said nitrous oxide just then what he
meant to say was AML nitrate so remember
Amal nitrate not nitrous
oxide but you can't ask for that you
have to ask for a video head tape
cleaner and if you ask for naous oxide
they'll say they don't have it but if
you ask for a video head tape cleaner
they will give you that so yeah it was
it was a porno shop yeah yeah yeah yeah
a porno shop and it was called like a
thunderbolt yeah yeah yeah and uh so
somehow you and I like uh you came over
at like 8:00 in the morning or something
we started our video head cleaner
huffing session and uh next thing you
know we we've got the idea to to go get
tattoo matching tattoos of the logo on
the can and like we we went over to uh
the nearest tattoo shop but they weren't
open until like 10:00 in the morning so
we just sat outside there land on the
the sidewalk just spraying it on a sock
and and we we sat there until they
opened up and we got our tattoos yeah
taine would get very upset around that
time if he walked up to me cuz I would
just dump it on my shirt and then HPP it
off my shirt and if he saw my shirt wet
he would start complaining wow yeah it's
it's nothing to
yeah yeah it's good to steer clear of it
are there any scenes in jackass for you
have a stain on your shirt probably
not the uh everybody's gonna be looking
for the what do you think about this
like um I've described that uh yeah
because people ask me if um it was
easier to do stunts because I was loaded
you know and and I said you know like
not not really like a an issue because
the spirit of Jackass was never to be
like visibly
intoxicated if we thought someone was
loaded we wouldn't let them do the stun
right exactly and and and I I I tell
people you know like Boogie Nights at
the end of Boogie Nights like Mark
Wahlberg is uh he's all like you know
messed up on on speed and he's just too
high and Bert Reynolds you know the the
the porn say I'm not going to shoot you
in this state so there are many times on
jackass that were very reminiscent of
that United you know I'm not going to
Chain's like I'm not going to shoot you
like this and I seem to recall that on
that same jackass number two that I was
supposed to be the one that got the dick
branded on my butt cheek but that the GU
came into my room because I wasn't to be
found at call time came into my room and
I was like laying there with blue lips
because I was all like flopping on the
ground with uh my nitrous oxide yeah and
and gu reported that to to traine like
oh his lips were all blue he's like
flopping on the ground like and like
inhaling nitrous oxide and uh and I got
I got the bur penals treatment and I
think I think that's why bam ended up
with the the the dick brand I don't
think that was your only time getting
the old B RS
treatment definitely not but man like
it's so great to be able to look back on
on all of that
and uh you know like from a good place
yeah like all our uh you know uh
whatever we tried mistakes uh I mean
back then it wasn't even necessarily
mistakes we were just out of control and
it was working for us yeah you know like
and then it stopped it worked until it
didn't yeah until the wheels fell off
and you like have to formulate a new
plan M you know I can't live that way
anymore more but I did yeah well dude I
I love it I love you I love you man and
um yeah man I appreciate you I think
that we should we should make a point to
reach out to each other and say hey like
let's just get together when it's not
for for work yeah yeah go have a little
uh Bagel or
shme and were you pulling up our new hot
[__] skatebo deck I I think I'm I'm
going to uh
like the way you did the last one was
Hart and
Knoxville I'm going to ask you to do one
like that yeah yeah yeah here you go and
and it's just I I wonder if like if if
it's up here cuz you know when we're
signing you know like cuz we're one up
top and one down below or I don't know
well you know it's interesting the the
guys at the warehouse found a pattern in
your signing you you always signed Hart
Knoxville like how you normally do but
then when you take a break or you go on
your phone or if you went to the
bathroom and came back the first
signature was always Johnny oxville yeah
it was just random like every now and
then I would screw up but
then it's like well somebody gets the
full signature yeah I think it's a cool
little Easter egg people can
find and look at this penmanship
steo I think get strongly worded text I
think that is smaller then I think you
get more more real estate but then again
I don't know well with that we'll see
whatever whatever uh ends up on the
website when these available when will
they be oh they're available now they
are available now available now do do we
do we wait until this comes out before
we yeah yeah now we oh so I mean do we
tell people about the skateboards now or
yeah they this episode's next week right
this episode's next week we will we will
have signed but next week this will be
today
yes there you go okay so have we got a
day scheduled to sign the boards uh
we'll get one to you early before this
comes
out
okay all right they are available now so
everybody go to sto.com for the new
JohnnyO 2.0 skateboard and sto's bucket
list the w wildly messed up and tonally
dark multi exciting very exciting
groundbreaking
hilarious I I love you captain man love
you buddy all
right did I tell you or what he really
opened up about his checkered past and I
thought it was great I also think this
is great ladies and gentlemen the Johnny
O
2.0 and uh if I'm GNA tell you we don't
have many of these we're trying to get
more we can't all man so hurry up and
grab it at sto.com and as always my
beautiful street team I love you so so
much yeah
dude see that